as we Mark Veterans Day and celebrate
those who have served and sacrificed we
are taking a look at a group with a
mission to connect veterans through
adventures in mountain biking the dirt
therapy project is a non-profit it
started by a retired marine and it aims
to restore the unique sense of
camaraderie that former service members
often miss and help some heal from the
wounds of War Omar villafranca caught up
with these Weekend Warriors in the Texas
Hill Country
all downhill from there
Army veteran Travis strong is no
stranger to heart pumping action from
skydiving to skiing
to surfing strong says he's always been
a bit of a daredevil but after surviving
a life-threatening Battlefield injury he
now just wants to show himself and
others that anything is possible
November 27th of 2006 was when it
actually happened we were just doing a
night Mission it kind of started off
really weird quiet strong was on his
second deployment to Baghdad when a
roadside bomb tore through the armored
vehicle he was riding in it took my
right leg off instantly and my left leg
was kind of really mangled but I didn't
feel any pain I didn't know I was even
hit at that point in time and then
everything just started to go black
I can feel myself just like draining out
like my life's just draining and I'm
like oh I'm I'm gonna die like I'm dead
doctors at a field Hospital were able to
save his life but not his legs at that
time I was just trying to think of what
my life would be like without legs and
just trying to figure out what can and
what I can I do you know the cans now
far outweigh the cannots strong even
hopes to Summit tanzania's Mount
Kilimanjaro next year but today he faces
a slightly smaller Peak hitting the
trails on this adaptive suspension trike
so this is gonna be your first time
coming down the mountains yes what do
you expected
um just have fun go down the trike was
loaned to him by a non-profit started by
another combat veteran Jonathan Hagerman
I grew up in a military family my dad
was Air Force and so it was always kind
of something that I knew I wanted to do
after four years of service including a
deployment to Afghanistan Hagerman
returned to civilian life and went back
to school what were you missing after
you left the Marines man that's a tough
question you build these bonds and these
friendships that you can't make anywhere
else for four years I had been on active
duty every single day I woke up I knew
what I was going to wear I knew where I
was allowed to go and then you separate
and it's like oh go do whatever you want
what is it that I want to do after a few
months of seeing the stress relieving
benefits of this Outlet on Wheels
Hagerman started the dirt therapy
project the mission helping other
veterans heal and connect through biking
the organization's first annual Veterans
Day event brought 150 veterans together
in Texas including strong and his
girlfriend Brittany a two-year Army vet
and competitive biker who couldn't wait
to hit the downhill dirt would you what
are you expecting on this mountain
he'll probably do stuff where we're all
going to go what the heck just happened
that's him so the brakes are not going
to get any use with him no probably not
[Applause]
when you're racing or when you're going
down a hill does it give you something
that you can't get anywhere else
a sense of freedom because pretty much
you're equal to everybody up there on
the mountain you can pretty much do
anything that they can do
so it's so sick this this helps me as
much as it helps anybody who comes out
to ride with us I'm becoming a better
version of myself
alongside other folks who are doing the
same thing I like to lead by example and
show what's possible instead of telling
other people hey do this when you're
doing it too and they can look at you
and go well I've got no excuse now for
CBS mornings I'm Omar villafranca in
Burnet Texas
well I take it back Mr strong and Mr
Hagerman when I said that looks scary
when you hear what they've been through
they could say Gail we have seen scary
that is not scary Bravo to them that
they could do it and I love it he said
you know I can do anything that anybody
else can do while I'm up here yes he
might be limited physically but he's
Limitless he's Limitless he's doing a
lot more than everyone else is doing I
see why they call it dirt therapy
totally get it yeah you want to do it
sometime soon no but we're cheering them
on okay moving on all right